So what's a different representation?
Well it's nothing more
recent newer approach,
it's what's referred to as point clouds.
And point clouds are essentially,
you take all of your depth
pixels that you hit.
And you say, aha that's a little,
we used to use the word voxel,
that's a little voxel of stuff.
And I'm just going to hang
it out there in space and so
I would get this constellation
of points that's just a cloud.
Okay, now I actually can't
see inside surfaces, so
it's maybe a cloud that I
can only see the outside of.
But if I had like another camera and
I knew how those cameras were related.
I could take the points that it saw and
stick them out in the same cloud area.
And eventually, I would have this
big point cloud of depth points and
it would be a lot easier to reason
about the geometry of those.
Now of course,
when we do this that point cloud sort of
doesn't know how it got created, right?
So did I look at it from here or
did I look at it from there?
So, I don't have that free
space information anymore.
So point clouds of course,
have their advantages and disadvantages.
The biggest one is probably that
it's viewpoint independent, right?
So, because it's viewpoint independent,
I can
merge different point clouds as long as
they're in the same coordinate system.
And I can actually reason
more about the geometry.
The disadvantages include,
so for example it's not,
it might not be very dense, right?
And in depth image,
I've got depth everywhere.
Point clouds,
whatever points I got, I got.
And if I want to know what's
the depth going this way,
I might not know the answer,
I just know about these set of points.
And so fundamentally, you've also
lost this free space stuff, okay?
Because you don't know how we,
so I have a point right here,
I don't know if it was viewed
from this way or from this way.
If it was viewed this way, I know that
all these pixels along this ray are free
from here to over there, I don't have
that representation in point clouds.
The other thing is as I get
further away essentially my cloud,
each individual pixel that I see is
taking up a bigger and bigger voxel.
So the point cloud density, sorry,
the point cloud resolution, you know,
how big is a point cloud, point.
The resolution is determined by
how far way from the depth sensor
I observe that point, so
nearby ones are tight little points,
further back, they're bigger voxels.
But I didn't tell you yet
about the biggest advantage,
the biggest advantage about point
clouds is the point cloud library.
There's all this code out there and
it continues to grow, called PCL for
the manipulation of point clouds.
And so, that's code you don't
have to write, all right?
So, it allows you to operate on depth,
just not worrying about
the details of the bookkeeping
about these depth representations.
So that's, that's really a huge element.
And one might even say if it wasn't for
the PCL, the Point Cloud Library,
point clouds would not be
nearly as popular as they are.
Eh, here's a, [COUGH] here's
a pointer to, what's the website?
Pointclouds.org, all right?
Which tells you something, right?
.org, this is open source.
So it continues to, to grow,
and continues to improve.